été visés par des sanctions
chinoises ce qui pèse
sur l'économie de Taïwan.
Philippe Leblanc, est allé
constater ses impacts sur
les éleveurs du poisson mérou,
un produit interdit en Chine
depuis déjà deux
contempler son avenir incertain.
Comme les autres éleveurs
de mérou taïwanais, il a perdu
d'un seul coup 80 % de
son marché il y a
Il se sent pris en otage,
sans moyen de défense.
Prétextant des taux de
contamination élevés à certains
produits chimiques, la Chine
a suspendu l'importation
Lin Song-Cong croit que
comme lui feront pression sur
leur gouvernement
change ses politiques à l'égard
de la Chine.
"Je vais perdre de l'argent,
dit-il, mais que puis-je faire?
imposent leur volonté."
Les tactiques d'intimidation
économique de la contre Taïwan
ont pris une toutene derniène de
contre la venue de Nancy Pelosi
sur l'île, la Chine a interdit
l'importation de thé, agrumes
et de de, ce qui affecte
des centaines d'entreprises.
La Chine a également suspendu
temporairement l'envoi de terres
rares àtoucher la production dus
grand joueur mondial de
l'industrie du semi-conducteur,
TSMC, fournisseur entre autres
r les débouchés pour
les produits taïwanais...
Et préparer des dumplings
avec les surplus de mérou,
un poissen raison de l'embargo
chinois.
Fang Shu-Fang en prépare 400
à 500 par jour à elle seule.
pas le poisson, dit-elle.
peut-être les encourager
à en manger." Des produits à bau
ont même contribué à faire
augmenter les vent..............
L'interdiction d'importation
du mérou en Chine a donc offerts
exceptionnelle pour cette coop.
Taïwan produit environ 6000
tonnes de mérou par année.
à elle seule le marché chinois.
Les élevhent
à développer de nouveaux
marchés, dont le CMais Lin Songà
de réduire du tiers sa capacité
limiter les pertes. Ces étangs
sont sa vie, en 40vage
de mérous, il n'a jamais été
aussi inquiet.anc,
Radio-Canada, Kaohsiung,
dans le sud de l'île de Taïwan.